baby girl
[Laughter]
what is going on i mean what is look
look you and emmy
yeah she's pretty you said you're gonna
put her in your daughter's room yes i am
yes yeah my little seven-year-old
sausage face i'm gonna put it in her
room because i want her to know that i
don't ever go away from her lightly i'm
a single mom and i need her to know that
i've got a damn good reason for going
and i'll always scuttle back shout out
to all the single mamas out there you
said it on stage you said like
possibilities
exactly and i and i i don't care where
people get bored of me saying it it's a
big deal being a single mom it's not
something any of us ever planned on
being and we plow on and you're also
showing her the example of like
how a woman walks through this world and
walks in her womanness you know
come on jamie
jamie
listen the whole cast i'm like good lord
y'all bad you'll scrub before what's the
night bring um
don't get to see each other very often
so yeah it's gonna get messy and also
you mentioned that it's important to
hire folks who are on the stage from
theater because they can translate and
do it there yes and and their and their
workhorses i was in western musical
theater for 20 years and
i i don't care who hears it west end
musical theater and british musical
theater performers
are
sometimes treated like second-rate
citizens and don't get don't get even
allowed into a casting and if they just
let them in they're not going to let you
down
brett's behind here let's bring him on
over here get in here
we saw you two holding hands going down
the car kevin show them the shot because
yeah
kevin saw you guys and he took the great
it was a great shot i ran down there
because i was like oh my god you got to
see this picture of these he made magic
holding hands as they walk down the
carpet i need kevin to have his stuff
ready y'all go y'all talk while i get
this out by the way just gently stalking
brett did you know that you dropped the
f-bomb that does not sound like me
that sounds like an accusation i can't
understand
look at these two holding hands walking
down the path
i mean
yeah well we're pals we all are we all
are we dig each other it's really really
nauseating i mean take me back to that
moment when they open up the envelope
and what do you mean when my butt cheeks
had barely touched them
there's a chair before i was up against
scary moment right yeah and i hadn't i
hadn't
well he knows he kept going i think you
should prepare something and i was like
but i can't hear you
i don't know
anything right yeah she really should
have
yeah that would have been
a pretty good move
when you hear your name i mean what is
that like what goes through your head is
an out of body experience what it sounds
like you know the teacher in peanuts
that goes
what was it like for you yeah i actually
was like who was it
i said who'd they say and then everyone
stood up but they were looking at me
like that right wait and then thank god
it had it written on the thing because i
was like
oh yeah yeah
that's me
that's what he meant he told you not to
curse who who gave you the speech quite
a number of people over over like the
build-up to this was saying just to just
listen man like this is a big show and
it's like an afternoon show and it's
like you really really shouldn't swear
and i was like okay
did we both drop the f-bomb yes you did
yeah my parents are going to be so
disappointed right you just want an emmy
you could have done whatever to do
whatever you want to do i'm going to
tell you
don't
invite us on the stage if you don't want
us to swear there you go there we go you
know this one's a fun follow on twitter
you're a very fun follow on twitter it's
a fun follow in life more importantly oh
i can dig it i dig it now um hannah said
it was alcohol
this evening so what about for you to do
and i was like
yeah we are singing from the musical
the musical like gin into yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh it's on yeah oh we've been
abstaining and now it's just on yeah i
love it go get it great time tonight
enjoy every single bit of this you guys
deserve thank you for bringing so much
joy to folks while we were locked in our
houses and life sucked this was a
difference man thank you to us i really
appreciate
that means the world